everyone is your boy psychobabble here
and with Kanye right here and you know
don't don't mind that don't mind this
guy right here you know oh [ __ ] is your
life thank you okay okay anyway um CI
magic grant up and exhale that's it okay
we're almost [ __ ] that Jesus I could
take like 30 years I gotta get some
[ __ ] trains in this place or cars
rent is high okay I see your match right
cats are going hello sir and I think
yeah I think yeah you shall see that one
that money takes you to an extremely
dangerous ok let's stand us let's do
this all right
it's more like carrie austin him
ok got
ok
the [ __ ] is this dude there's some dope
things in here
wow I like this place holy [ __ ] it's
like decorated actually
no I like that hammer
I guess there will anything a look at
here scotch yeah all right just right
ok else do this oh [ __ ]
yeah well this is I'm not worried cuz
this is the first time and it gently
it'll be the last time you know I didn't
date right so okay oh wow again you've
heard of the sierra madre casino we all
have the legend the curses foolishness
about it lying in the middle of the city
of the dead buried beneath a blood red
cloud of bright shining monument luring
treasure hunters to their doom the
world's most famous stars and
entertainers were invited to its grand
opening an invitation was a sign of
exclusiveness the opening was supposed
to symbolize a road to a brighter future
not just for the world but for all who
came to its dual cam a chance for anyone
to begin again except the sierra madre
never opened the war froze it in time
like a big flash bulb going off the
grand opening one big ending of humanity
it's still out there in the wastes
preserved just waiting for someone to
crack it open but getting to it that's
not the hard part it's letting go okay
and legos hard like I wear the same
lockers like nine days in a row and I
change it but they're usually dark brown
or red hello you busy good from place
stupid place it's like a boy on your
business do asses and the column there's
no escape from here until I live that
structure you see about the Phantom the
Sierra Madre disease but to get
installing avoid its tracks around alone
three other callers like yours call it a
and should you get any ideas about
teacher all your colors are wanted
because in some respects brick villas so
gorgeous sup once a week i downloaded
and get a up duelist good I've download
okay ow oh sure that I thought
okay that was the first quest so thank
you
you